a young mother of two children recently
lost her husband we have not identified
her at her request she doesn't believe
her husband was involved in any criminal
activities my husband used to work as a
simple day laborer in the camp he worked
very hard for his money it was after
four days that I found out that he was
killed by the security forces the recent
murder of a local ruling party
politician sparked violent attacks
against rahaga by some in the host
community instead of diffusing the
tension law enforcement officers
allegedly refused to intervene and
protect the refugees more than a dozen
grow hangars have been killed by
security forces in recent weeks most
were accused for their involvement in a
killing of a local ruling party
politician the atmosphere in this
refugee camps are very tense right now
authorities often linked these
extrajudicial killings to the drug human
trafficking and other criminal
activities another young woman who
became a widow recently thinks her
husband was wrongfully framed and killed
he was accused of drug smuggling
she says she's scared and he's now left
alone with her two children justice we
couldn't find it in my admirer after all
the atrocities committed against us and
I don't expect to find any kind of
justice here for my husband's death in
the last two years since the Rohingya
Exodus to Bangladesh more than 46
Rohingya have been killed by security
forces some group are
Angus two different illegal activities
suppose drug trafficking and human
trafficking and other robbery like
criminal activities so the situation
based decision we have taken finally are
failed to control or arrest them then to
safe and secured our Foolish personal
and our life in that purpose sometimes
this type of gunfight happened
rights activists say these incidents are
unacceptable
two years on from the genocide in
Myanmar the sympathy and compassion
towards aranga in Bangladesh seems to be
slowly fading after a period of relative
calm and stability uncertainty and fear
are now haunting the refugees sandwich
Audrey al-jazeera Baloo Kali Cox's
Bazaar Bangladesh